wenn wir herausfinden irgendwie den
bachchor und dafür brauche ich ein paar
sachen guardians of the galaxy ist die
neueste marvel comic verfilmung regie
übernahm james caan bekannt für seine
respektlosen doch niemals herzlosen
filme schaltkasten
dahinter befindet sich eine chronik
batterie violette kiste grüne drehte um
in den wachturm zu kommen brauche ich
die auf jeden fall hier geht es vor
allem um superhelden und die
faszinierende vielfalt außerirdischen
lebens chris pratt spielt den helden
star lord den ein illustres ensemble und
gibt der bereich ist er am schwersten
bewachte im ganzen knast unmöglich daran
zu kommen ohne gesehen zu werden
der juristische waschbär roccatune der
sprechende humanoide baum groot zoe
saldana als profi mörderin und dave
battista als kriegs überlebender müssen
wir sehr schnell handelt deswegen müssen
wir sie definitiv als letztes mittel
oder wie hole ich als erstes und
improvisiert fallenlassen starts trupp
muss den tyrannen sängers aufhalten und
dem scheußlichen ronan ein objekt in
traisen mit dem man die wirklichkeit zu
kartoffelbrei zu manchen kann
hier knüpft guardians of the galaxy an
joss whedon the ventures von 2012 und
torte daqing von 2013 an
und auch wer das umfangreiche
quellenmaterial tausender von
comicseiten nicht kennt begreift um was
es geht und kann den film genießen
selbst nebenfiguren sind hochkarätig
besetzt
james caan hat den schauspielern freie
hand gelassen und entgegen allen
erwartungen das superhelden genre nicht
verwöhnt die scherze die kann sich
erlaubt sind geradezu süß hinzu kommen
anspielungen auf gute musik von früher
und fiktive technik von übermorgen sein
häuflein verwalter helden erfrischt das
marvel universum
schon vor